Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
marvel ant-man 3 trailer from comic-con quantum
mania there's a bunch of easter eggs in here
a bunch of stuff that's leading up to kang in
avengers 5 which is gonna be a version of kang
war called kang dynasty they're just changing
the name but it's basically a version of kang war
from the comics we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos ant-man 3 is going to be the
next movie after black panther wakanda forever
comes out ant-man 3 is coming out in february
next year so we wanted to wait that long but
obviously now because so much of marvel phase
4 phase 5 and phase 6 is confirmed to turn around
the kang the conqueror character or a version of
kang because there are many different versions of
kane we're going to see they said that the events
of ant-man 3 are going to shake the foundation
of the mcu in a way that the ant-man movies have
not done previously and most of the movie does
take place down in the quantum realm like that's
where he fights king the conqueror that's where
we see a version of modoc that's where we see
bill murray's character who seems like he's
playing a version of krylar from the comics
but i'll talk more about each of those characters
when we get to them in the trailer footage
this is one of the longest trailers that marvel
showed off at comic con because it is the next
movie after black panther wakanda forever there
was a guardians of the galaxy teaser trailer video
i'll do a separate video for later this week there
was a little bit of less footage for that but
it confirmed a bunch of big details they didn't
release the trailer online so i have to be kind of
careful the way i use the footage from the actual
trailer in the video here but as the trailer
footage starts they show that scott lang is very
pleased with his life in present-day post avengers
end game he's parlied his role from saving the
world from thanos to become internationally famous
they show him in a bookstore reading a book that
he wrote called watch out for the little guy quote
unquote that's become a best seller so like he's
made a bunch of money somebody tell falcon that if
he needs a bank loan to call scott lang because
apparently scott lang is flush with cash now
then you start to hear voiceover from jonathan
major's king the conqueror character and he's not
playing the same version that we saw during the
loki finale that was the he who remains version
of kang this new king the conqueror is meant
to be a variant to that character and there
are a couple different versions that you see of
him in the trailer like in one he's wearing his
classic king the conqueror blue looking suit i'll
explain how it's a little bit different in the mcu
they made it look a little bit more practical
and in one of the other scenes he looks just like
regular jonathan majors without his mask on with
his regular skin tone so like his face won't be
blue like it is in the comics the blue actually
comes from the mask that he wears when he's in the
quantum realm with a special king the conqueror
suit like they're treating his king the conqueror
suit from the comics which you see in the poster
here like this is kind of what he looks like in
his king the conqueror suit with the mask around
his head the blue just comes from the mask that
goes over his head this is basically what king the
conqueror looks like in his full kang suit but his
voice over starts by saying you're an interesting
man scott lang you've lost a lot of time
but time isn't what you think it's not a straight
line and while he's doing this voiceover they
flash through a bunch of different scenes of scott
lang just enjoying his life as a celebrity like
you see him and hope van dyne at this big premiere
party the reference to him losing a lot of time is
him losing time with his daughter missing the five
years that he was stuck in the quantum realm where
she grew up into a teenager obviously they've
recast catherine newton as a version of his
teenage daughter she's like an older teenager
now because catherine newton is in her 20s
who in this trailer has become the stinger version
of the character you can see a version of her suit
in the poster here in the comics the stinger
identity that she adopts is a relatively recent
thing her stinger costume is basically just like
an upgraded version of hope van dyne's wasp suit
so she has pretty much the same powers as the wasp
has in the young avengers comics she was known as
stature and she was more like a version of giant
woman like her big thing was growing really huge
so they have changed that during this movie like
she'll be more like the wasp during this movie
there were some deleted scenes of young cassie
lang and ant-man the wasp going small with scott
lang having adventures really tiny size with
the ants wearing a more traditional version
of the ant-man suit so as a teenager
it just seems like she's been active
as the stinger character wearing this version of
the stinger suit for a little while now in walking
the conker is doing his initial voiceover talking
about how time isn't what scott lang thinks it is
in a different part of the movie during this
big montage he gets a phone call from the san
francisco police department saying that cassie
lang has been arrested and he goes to pick her up
it sounds like she's just getting into trouble the
same way that he got into trouble when he was busy
becoming ant-man like she has a lot of the same
qualities that he had like really resourceful but
winds up getting herself into all kinds of trouble
trying to be a superhero once scott lang bails her
out there's a scene of them also happening during
this early jonathan majors kang voice over where
they're all having dinner at the pym's house this
is hank pym's house so it's like scott lang cassie
hope hank pym janet van dyne all them together
and they're all making fun of scott lang for
trying to say that he's so famous all the time
in talking about the time that he saved the world
it's kind of like the other avengers making fun
of iron man for reminding everyone all the time
about how he saved the world during the first
avengers movie anybody remember when i carried
a nuke through a wormhole no it's never come
out save new york never heard that recall that
then there's a completely separate scene of them
in hank pym's lab doing an experiment together
where a vortex opens up and sucks cassie lange
into the quantum realm first and then the rest
of them gets sucked into the quantum realm
separately and when the accident happens you
see this blue light open up and it's kind of like
the same blue color that you see from the portal
that mr fantastic from the fantastic four opens
up they did confirm that that was meant to be an
easter egg for doctor doom's time travel platform
and eventually king the conqueror in the comics
le jonathan krasinski's reed richards was using
quantum energy to power his portal technology
in his design of portals look kind of like the tva
portals that he who remains kang had them using
as we're getting sucked into the quantum realm
kang the conqueror says time is not a straight
line then i think it's hope van dyne or cassie
lang who says where are we and you see them
inside the quantum realm and here's the thing
the environment where you're at you see all this
traditional looking quantum energy arcing around
them and it kind of looks like a bunch of blood
vessels around them it looks exactly like the
zoomed in view of the signal coming from inside
the ten rings in the shangxi post-credits scene
so like when they zoom in they see that mystery
signal who's it broadcasting to what is this
signal what's going on here now it seems more like
there's a connection between that signal and king
the conqueror and what's happening in ant-man 3
then pretty much all the rest of the footage in
the trailer and there's a lot of footage is all
inside different places in the quantum realm like
you go into the quantum city which we saw a view
of during ant-man and the wasp like we didn't
actually travel there but we saw the quantum city
in the background the idea was that when janet van
dyne was stuck in there for all those years she'd
spent time in the quantum city and she learned
about all the organisms that lived down there
then as they start walking around the quantum city
showing you these different areas these different
structures king the conqueror says maybe you can
see time the way i do you can see everything then
janet van dyne and hope van dyne are separately
together walking through the quantum city trying
to find everyone and you see bill murray's
character for the first time and it looks like
actual bill murray like he looks kind of like
a human who's inside the quantum realm but the
rumor is that he's playing a version of the
crylar character who is like an alien that
lives in the quantum realm in the comics they
called it the microverse but the iep for that
doesn't belong to marvel so they just changed the
name from microverse to quantum realm he said that
he's meant to be one of the villains in the movie
maybe not the main villain but one of the villains
he recognizes janet van dyne as if they know
each other either from her time being stuck in
the quantum realm previously or he's also a human
who just is now in the quantum realm as well using
his own technology it remembers her from before
she got stuck in the quantum realm when they were
much younger then you see a bunch of blue energy
arcing around different structures that looks more
like the timeline that you saw in the loki finale
like the sacred timeline when you were outside of
the timeline just watching it arc across space
and this seems like a reference to the actual
timeline the way that king the conqueror
manipulates time you start to see visions
of king the conqueror but they show him in really
roundabout ways and different types of structures
whatever machine he's using to manipulate time and
space you get more king the conqueror voice over
he says your world your reality everything you're
holding on to everything you call life i know how
it ends which is a reference to kang controlling
the entire timeline or feeling like he controls
the entire timeline they show you a montage of
a bunch of kang the conqueror structures and
during this there's a separate scene of a version
of modok and he looks a little bit different from
what we've seen in the comics before it's more
of a giant metal mask with a couple eye pieces
there's another mystery character here i'm not
sure who this is supposed to be none of the
interviews that all the websites did after this at
comic con mention who she's supposed to be playing
but it's also in the quantum realm you see janet
van dyne fighting what looks like another quantum
monster down here in the quantum realm then they
have another funny scene of scott lang trying to
face king the conqueror meeting him for the first
time they revealed him walking in with his feet
first then they slowly pan up and reveal that it's
jonathan majors king the conqueror and he's not
wearing his mask like it's actual jonathan major's
face and you hear scott lang saying um i don't
know who you think you are but you've made a big
mistake i'm an avenger then it pauses and you see
the full reveal of his face as jonathan major's
face it looks like he who remains version of kang
but it is meant to be the different variant
who's a version of king the conqueror
and he kind of quizzically tells him oh
you're an avenger like oh that's surprising
i'm a conker like he's completely unperturbed by
scott lang showing up saying that he's an avenger
because obviously king the conqueror knows who
the avengers are then when they transition to the
title scene the way they reveal the title it looks
kind of like a bunch of timelines arcing across
space which is just meant to be a reference back
to kang the conquer and what you saw in the loki
finale with all the different timelines one of the
other big reveals at comic-con was that avengers 5
is going to be a version of kang dynasty that
they're calling it but it's basically like their
version of kang war from the comics kang war is
like one of the first big avengers arcs during
the all-new all different era it was meant to be
a completely new avengers team fighting a version
of kang across the timeline and during that story
it featured a bunch of different versions of him
across his own timeline but the big difference
in the mcu version is that it was meant to be
a single version of kang from different points
in his own timeline like it wasn't a bunch of
different variants of kang i'm sure there's a
thousand questions about what was going on in
the ant-man 3 trailer so if you have any questions
about that just write them below in the comments
i'll do a separate video tomorrow for like
the full avengers 5 teaser for kang dynasty
and for avengers 6 secret wars because they're
trying to release those in the same year they're
kind of doing the same thing with infinity war and
end game where it's one giant story with two very
different parts broken into a big cliffhanger
in the cliffhanger this time will be basically
like the last remaining universe forming them
forming battle world for the secret wars movie
everyone click here for my black panther wakanda
forever trailer video in easter eggs and click
here for my brand new she-hulk trailer video
in easter eggs including daredevil coming back
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!